Doug Gottlieb Fox Sports college
basketball analysts the Doug Gottlieb
show on Fox Sports Radio I heart app and
Doug joins us know good morning Doug how
are you I'm great what a great weekend
at hoops yeah I was curious let me start
with the coaching decision with Coach K
in the you know final seconds thereof
going to RJ Barrett instead of Zion
Williamson I know we had the benefit of
you know hindsight here but in the
moment what did you think Coach K was
going to do well again if you ask any
basketball guy who's been around the
high school in AAU circuit for the last
five years don't tell you that RJ
Barrett was seen as one of the best
closers at this age that we'd ever seen
that's what he does he makes plays down
the stretch you know you go back and
look at what he did with Team Canada and
what he's been leading up to this point
I also think I don't know necessarily if
it was to go to like what they basically
ran was they they tried to get the ball
to Zion and spread out and let him go
one-on-one and if he couldn't get past
this man he passed star shape and then
RJ would try and do the same thing and
they had spacing issues because they
just don't have enough shooting site I
don't know if it was specifically hey
we're going to rji so everybody got all
the way Michael Jordan when he first got
in the NBA but I would tell you that you
know RJ missed a free throw I you know
he got to the free-throw line a chance
to make a free throw to tie the
basketball game he missed one but I mean
that was RJ not coming through was
actually a huge surprise for most people
who followed him his game's not perfect
but he's a hell of a player and a great
competitor and one that seen as a great
closer where would you put Zion this
one-and-done year as far as exciting
college basketball players exciting
college basketball players exciting I
can't think of anything more exciting
than watching and I've you know look
I've my entire life I've watched this
tournament and my entire professional
life after two and a half years of
professional basketball has been
covering this sport I've never been more
excited because he it's a combination
right it's the jaw-dropping athleticism
at both ends like most kids when they're
freshmen it's like they play like the
courts tilted you running forwards
they're great they have backwards like
yeah you know I just do that to to make
to make ends meet
but you know there was a play he made in
the sweet 16 where his knees kind of got
buckled in transition trying to guard
the ball and he was beaten and then he
recovered and blocked the shot I'm like
did I that it's unbelievable so in terms
of excitement and then you could kind of
feel like you watched him improving as
you watched him play more games like if
you watch him a start of the year he was
good but he was getting more comfortable
shooting the basketball he's getting
more comfortable in terms of of how he
handles the ball in the perimeter
against different types of pressure
defenses he's obviously a very very
active and athletic post player and and
there's some floss you see they're
putting triples exciting use that word
oh dude I mean tell me something you've
been more excited to see than Zion
Williams and play college basketball I
can't remember if you could have one
player in this tournament for one game
right now
Zion Barret Carson Edwards Cassius
Winston JA Marant other just for a
college game yeah I mean college game is
different than a pro game I hope
everybody understands that spacing is
different the talent is different the
length of repoint shot Cassius Winston
and it's I'm not sure it's close wow I
mean this dude yeah I mean you're going
to Minneapolis you guys got your you
guys are bringing your trigger grills
and you're gonna do some ice fishing and
all that stuff you guys did I don't you
still do ice fishing that stuff was
hilarious you guys did last time but but
you walk up to him and like I don't get
it
you know he's kind of he's not cut you
know he's tastic he's not crazy
explosive but I mean like look the guy's
the Big Ten Player of the Year because
at the end of the shot clock he just
finds a way to make it happen
finds away you know he you put a small
guard on him he'll Drive you in and kind
of bump you and big boy yeah and shoot a
floater over
if you pack up he'll shoot of three and
then when he gets in the lane again it
what they really want is they want to
get a big guy on him and then on a
switch it's not like he blows by people
but it just gets enough of a step so
yeah I mean at this level in this sport
in this tournament
give me Cassius Winston I mean look the
Matt Mooney at Texas Texas Tech would be
in the conversation in terms of like
veteran guards just have a great ease
and pace about them Jared Harper little
point guard at Auburn and what a stud
and of course Bryce Brown is running
mate but I'd give me Cassius Winston
just I've watched him the whole year
he's been like this every seemingly
every game well and that's what I was
telling people when Carson Edwards is
putting on that shooting display I said
you know he wasn't the conference player
the year they're like how was he not
Conference Player of the Year and I said
it's Cash's Winston of Michigan State
and they're going whoo and I said well
you have to watch him because when you
needed a big hoop he gave you a big hoop
no you know and he's the biggest reason
why Michigan State is here it's really
uncool and you know the car that we're
saying and I'm sure you're like look if
you watched him in the big ten you're
nodding your head like maybe I haven't
seen it on this biggest stage you know
that dudes a walking bucket on the other
hand like there's the you know there are
games in which it's really bad and it
can get really selfish and they kind of
got to work around it and they've
actually been better when he's shot less
at times I mean but I think that's the
thing I wake up with today Dan is that
we do kind of forget the sweet 16 games
were there was a I mean Purdue Tennessee
was an incredible game but no one talks
about them they just get caught up in
the wash and some of it is because of
timing you know it's sports radio on a
Monday and then the the Elite Eight
games a day later and some of it is
because somebody's because you know
these Elite Eight games were there I
don't know if any one game was better
than all the rest but I can't think of a
weekend which we had four games that
were that close I mean like what Tony
Bennett goes from not making the Final
Four where Purdue fouls up three five
point whatever seconds to go to sending
it into overtime I mean in the series of
things that have to go your way
you fat when you get fouled down three
points like they all went the way of
Virginia and then they still have to go
win the game in overtime so that was
what a weekend what do you think Zion
Williamson's doing today I mean I think
he's probably waking up super sore super
sad where she was till plan what do you
mean in terms of you think he's packing
his stuff yeah do you think he's going
to class I don't know I'd love to know I
don't know I mean I I remember I was
covering consignee town I did Kentucky's
last home game when when they went
undefeated in the regular season that
year was a couple years ago right and I
remember karl-anthony towns he had a
game on like a Tuesday or whatever and
then you know I rolled in maybe on a
Thursday they're like yeah he went to
class on Wednesday I mean first all the
girls are class so if you wanna meet the
girls as we go but but you know like I
don't it sound like class is gonna kill
you you want and Plus you want to leave
in good academic standing but I also
don't know if Dukes on spring break or
or whatever I don't know I'm sure to
find out I'm sure social media love us
I'm sure some of those guys you know
they're they think of themselves
professionals they got a pack their
stuff and they're they're out the
Kentucky guys I'm sure there's several
guys like that but but not all of them
built that way and some of them actually
think that the let me finish up strong I
only have till May and I can still get
my workouts in I mean the idea that you
somehow like there's some workout coach
it's gonna fix you and change you and
make you better for like no it's not
like go to class go to your workouts you
know if you have a private workout guy
work it out with a coach they'll come
working out the facility that's the way
it works you're gonna be in Minneapolis
we're gonna see yeah yeah yeah we're
doing what we're doing drinks on McLovin
right that's that's what you told me you
just send me a text no it wouldn't be on
me buddy
No No maybe drinks on Seaton but not
McLovin back row definitely not
definitely a back row is really tight
really tight with the wall really really
I thought you know making them pay for
the
new chairs the new band cave I thought
that was easy look hazy if I tell you
something you shouldn't be bringing it
up until we unveiled a new man I've seen
advertisements for the thing what you
talking about like like this these are
the state held secrets I wasn't aware of
yes they are they are state held secrets
for the big unveiling who do you have
winning at all well my son has Michigan
State winning at all and he's 10 and so
he was convinced because I've made him
watch watch catches Lincoln play all
year he's like wow that you told me to
watch him I was like yeah but I like I
like Clark to I like all these other
guys so I guess we're going wish you can
stay and this is a really amazing what
Bruce pearls done without Juma yeah you
know Texas Tech losing for starters I
mean I'm telling like you can you can
appreciate this you understand how great
a coach Bob Knight is or was whatever
and because of how because he went to
ESPN too late in his career because he
became kind of a grumpy old man and kind
of a caricature of himself
I do think Chris beard is a living
embodiment of his coaching principles
and I I think it'd be a good weekend to
remember that I mean you remember how
big a figure he was in college
basketball
I mean look Mike Chevy is a coach is a
Bob Knight disciple and everybody kind
of forgets all that because well you
know how he got why he got fired I you
and how he ends his career but Chris
beers a good coach that I've ever seen
draw up and of course he's going against
Izzo who's right there in that
conversation
thank you Doug seeing a couple of days I
brother that's Doug Gottlieb funk sports
the Doug Gottlieb show for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show at
you